I want to continue in volume three, taking up at April the 10th, 1900, and the subject
is desire.
Blessed Jesus continues not to come, O God what an unspeakable pain his privation is.
I tried as much as I could to remain at peace and all abandoned in him, but no, my poor
heart could take no more.
I did as much as I could to come at, saying my heart let his weight a little longer, who
knows he might come, let us use some strategies to draw him to come.
So again I want to give you Sam 42 there and Sam 63, they're the Sams that explain her pain.
So that's Sam 42 and Sam 63.
So Louisa said, turning to him I said, Lord come, it's getting late and you haven't come.
This morning I am trying to remain calm as much as I can and yet you do not let yourself
be found.
Lord she said, I offer you the martyrdom of your privation as a proof of love and as
a gift to induce you to come.
Now this is perfect, absolutely perfect, that she offers it as a proof of her love and also
as a gift to induce him to come.
But once you start offering it in love, she's doing well.
It's true that I'm not worthy, but this is not because, but it's not because I'm worthy
that I look for you, rather I do it out of love and because without you I feel I'm not
alive.
And since he wasn't coming I said to him, Lord, either you come or I will tire you out
with my speaking, she says, actually what she means is my persistence.
And you have Luke chapter 11 verses 5 to 8 where Jesus tells us to persist in prayer
and if we do that you'll get what you want.
Now Luke 11 is telling us about the man who arrived in the middle of the night knocking
his neighbor up looking for bread.
And the neighbor said, go away the children are asleep, I don't want any disturbance.
But because the man persists in knocking it's actually easier to give them the bread than
to keep on saying go away.
So the man gets what he wants simply by persistence.
So the Louisa says that she will persist.
You also have that marvelous story and Luke 18 verses 1 to 9 of the woman with you on
just judge and no matter what he did to her or no matter what he said to her, she just
would not go away.
And just for the sake of getting rid of her, you have to give her what she wanted.
So this persistence is actually very important.
So Louisa said, I will persist until you get tired.
And even then you're not coming to me, she said, but who can say all my nonsense, Louisa
says, I told him so many things that would be too long if I wanted to say everything.
After this, I just barely saw my sweet Jesus moving in my interior.
Okay.
Now, again, I remind you of one Corinthians 3, 16, no, you're not that you are the temple
of the living God and that the spirit of God dwells inside of you.
And you also have Luke 17, 21, the kingdom of God is within.
So you look within, but Louisa is always wanting Jesus' trade dimensional outside of her as
well.
So it looked as if he was just barely waking up from sleep.
Now, it's like as if Jesus was asleep in the boat, do you remember the time of the storm
and the apostles thought that he just wasn't interested and they woke him up.
So that's Mark 4, 38.
And then he showed himself more clearly, she said, and transporting me outside of myself,
he told me, just as the bird flaps its wings when it's about to fly.
So does the soul flap the wings of humility at the flights of her desires.
And in that flapping, she sends a magnet that draws me, it attracts me in such a way that
while she takes wing to come to me, I take wing to come to her.
So I want to give you one Peter 5, 5 to 9.
If you bow before the power of God now, he will raise you up.
And Lord Louisa said, it shows that I lack the magnet of humility.
If I could spread the magnet of humility everywhere on my path, I would not have to
struggle so much in waiting and waiting for your coming.
So Jesus didn't get anywhere with that particular illustration with Louisa, but he should get
there somewhere with us, that he's telling us that the more we desire him to come, the
more he will come.
It's not very interesting to come to someone who doesn't want you or desire you, but if
somebody really wants you and desires you, it's so much easier to come.
So I want to give you Isaiah 40, 31, those who wait upon the Lord shall renew their strength.
They shall mount up with wings like the eagle.
They shall run and not be weary.
They shall walk and not faint.
So earlier on in this volume, Jesus told us about a passport to enter the kingdom.
In April the 16th, 1900, he tells us that there's got to be three signatures on the
passport to enter the beatitude on earth, okay?
So he's talking about on earth.
So after I went through most bitter days of preparation, Louisa said, and reproaches from
blessed Jesus because of my ingratitude and my resistance to his will and to his graces.
This morning upon coming he told me, my daughter, the passport to enter the attitude which the
soul can possess on this earth must be signed by three signatures.
And these are number one, resignation, number two, humility, and number three is obedience.
Resignation, humility, and obedience.
Now resignation first, Jesus said, perfect resignation to my will is wact, which melts
our wills and forms a single one between the two.
It's sugar and honey, however, at a small resistance to my will the wact separates, the
sugar becomes bitter and the honey turns to poison, oh dear.
Secondly, it's not sufficient to be resigned, but the soul must be convinced that the greatest
good for herself and the best way to glorify me is to always do my will.
The whole issue is divine will and love, that's the summary of the 36 volumes.
Here is the necessity for the signature of humility because humility produces knowledge.
And Hosea 4-6 tells us that without knowledge the people perish, okay?
So humility produces knowledge, sorry, produces this knowledge.
But who ennobles these two virtues, who fortifies them, who renders them persevering, who chains
them together in such a way that they cannot separate, who crowns them.
It is the third one, obedience.
Ah yes, completely destroying one's will and everything, which is material, obedience
spiritualizes everything and like a crown places itself around them.
So resignation and humility without obedience are subject instability.
But obedience, but with obedience, they will be fixed and stable.
Here is the strict necessity of the signature of obedience, so that this passport may circulate
in order to pass into the reign of spiritual beatitude, which is the soul can enjoy down
here on earth.
With these three signatures, the passport, sorry, without these three signatures, the
passport will have no value.
And the soul will be rejected by the reign of beatitude and will be forced to remain
in the reign of restlessness, of fears and of dangers.
And to her misfortune, she will have her own self as God.
And this self will have the court age of pride and rebellion, oh dear.
As we go through the volumes, higher and higher, Jesus will explain that in the early volumes
we have the entering into the divine will and what is important to actually enter into the
divine will.
As we go higher in the volumes, we then have what we have to do to actually remain in the
divine will and then the highest volumes bring the whole thing to perfection.
Now, as you watch this progression because it is a spiritual journey, the divine will
a spirituality is not a devotion, it's a journey and it's a mission.
And as we go on, it becomes clearer and clearer and clearer that to be one with somebody else,
you've got to be like them.
I know that sounds obvious, but to be like him, first of all, we have to have the signature
of humility to even think about it.
But the likeness to him is love, but that's not enough.
He is pure spirit and he has to enable us to move more and more and more towards the
spirit.
Our thoughts have to be spiritualized, our desires, our motivations, our actions, our
intellects, memory, will, heart and eventually our body.
And so the whole thing is a process of being spiritualized and divinized.
So what is happening to us here on earth is actually happening to the souls in purgatory,
that they are being spiritualized and divinized.
Well, I suppose death has enabled the spiritualizing process.
So they are being divinized more and more until they're ready for the complete union
with God.
But this was meant to happen on earth.
If we don't do it, the reign of beatitude, of course, is the reign of peace, the reign
of union with God, the reign of love.
The opposite of that is the reign of restlessness.
I've met so many people who've told me they've no peace of mind.
And if they've no peace of mind, they haven't even got the most basic union with God because
they haven't dealt with the stuff that's disturbing them.
So they're in the reign of restlessness.
And if you're in the reign of restlessness, fears are very much prominent in the reign
of restlessness.
And of course, danger towards sin is very much there as well.
And down at that level, you have your own self as your governing leader.
In other words, you are your own God.
And the more you succeed in being your own God, then you are ruled by pride and rebellion
and you become a perfect symbol of the enemy.
So the choice that's put before us is either to become a perfect reflection of the Lord
or a terrible reflection of the other side.
We either enter into light or into darkness.
So after this, Louisa said, he carried me outside of myself into a garden and it seemed
to be the garden of the church.
There I saw five or six people, priests and others.
Now I usually say laity, but it's also people outside the church, ordinary people in society,
who were going astray and they were uniting themselves to the enemies of the church.
Now that means they're getting involved with modernism and rationalism and Marxism and
secularism and humanism and materialism and all the other stuff that's being launched
onto the 20th century.
And they started a revolution.
Now a revolution is that you go against the will of God and you bring lots of other people
into the thing as well.
So the other word for that would be apostasy.
How pitiful it was to see blessed Jesus crying over the sad state of these people.
Why?
Because he paid for their redemption.
He loves them.
They are his.
They are his by right of the fact that he's the creator and that he is the Redeemer.
Jesus said, "Then I looked in the air and I saw a cloud of water full of large pieces
of ice, in other words a terrible hail falling upon the earth."
Now the Bible always considered a serious hail storm when the hail stones are huge.
The Bible usually considers that as a very serious chastisement and towards the end of
the 20th century there were hail storms in Australia that destroyed cars and houses
and killed people.
Because a hail with that size is a bit like being bombarded from heaven.
What a disaster they caused upon harvest and upon humanity, Louisa said.
So you need your Amos 3-7.
The Lord tells his prophets ahead of time.
But I hope that he will calm down and then more afflicted than never Louisa said, "I
went back to myself."
On April the 20th 1900 we deal with the cross.
So you'll notice the cross-love entry into Beatitude, the mortification to hold us back.
Notice the whole platform is being described for us to actually pass from our old worldly
sinful way of life into this new life.
My adorable Jesus continues to come, but just a little and like a shadow.
And even when he comes he doesn't say anything, that's because he's chastising, you see.
This morning after he renewed in me the pains of the cross twice, looking at me with tenderness
while I was suffering the spasm of the piercing of the nails, and he said to me, "The cross
is a mirror in which the soul admires the divinity."
Well, that's Philippians 2 from verses 6 to 11.
His state was divine, but he did not cling to his equality with God.
He was humbler and he became as men are, but he was humbler yet, even accepting death,
death on a cross.
And that's why God exalted him and gave him the name that is above all names.
And the name that is above all names is Yawfi, which the Jewish people never pronounce out
of respect.
The soul admires the divinity, and by reflecting herself in it, she acquires the features and
the likeness that most resembled God.
Now, to reflect ourselves in it is 2 Corinthians 3, 18, where St. Paul tells us that the more
we contemplate God, the more we become like him.
So, by reflecting herself in it, she acquires the features and the likeness which most resembles
God.
The cross must not only be loved and desires, but one must consider it an honor and a glory.
Now, most people don't consider the cross an honor and a glory when they have it, or
yes, they'll admit that it is for Jesus, but not for themselves.
This is to operate like God, okay?
And to become like God by participation, because I alone gloried in the cross and considered
suffering an honor.
And I loved it so much that in my whole life, I did not want to be one moment without the
cross.
So I want to give you Philippians chapter 3 verses 8 to 16.
I want to give you Galatians 6, 14.
I want to give you Hebrews 12, 2, Colossians 1, 20 and Colossians 2, 14.
So, Jesus, what didn't want to be without the cross, that means paying the price for
other people to be set free, or what we call redemptive suffering.
So, Louisa says, who can say what I understood about the cross from this teaching of Jesus?
But I feel mute in expressing it in words.
"Allor, I pray you to keep me always nailed to the cross so that having this divine mirror
ever before me, I may clean all my stains and embellish myself evermore in your likeness."
Now, in these early volumes, Louisa continuously says that when she's in this out of the body
experience that she understands things very well.
When she comes back into the body, then the body itself puts a veil on all these matters
of the spirit.
And it's only as we watch her in these volumes, if we persevere, that we will watch her becoming
more and more spiritualized.
And the more she does, the more she's able to express it.
It's really fascinating what happens, and so you find in these early volumes that the
messages she gives us are all short, only two or three paragraphs.
When you go up into the higher volumes, you can have three or four A4 pages for one message.
So Louisa has been liberated to be able to express the divine things on paper.
But we won't jump because we need to take that journey step-by-step together.
So April the 21st, 1900, and again we're talking about the cross.
Have you noticed that when a subject comes up, you very often get a number of messages
all on the same theme?
As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, or rather a little bit of concern about something
which is not necessary to say here.
"Sweet Jesus on coming said to me, 'And they are sacred vessels,' he said.
And every once in a while it is necessary to dust them off.
Now Louisa's starting in the middle of a sentence.
Whatever Jesus said before this, we don't know, because she didn't write it down.
The only point at which he began to write is when Jesus said, 'And they are sacred vessels.'
And every once in a while it is necessary to dust them off.
Now he says, 'Your bodies are as many sacred vessels.'
That's one Corinthians 3, 16, and two Corinthians 6, 16, 'In which I make my dwelling, therefore
it is necessary that I do some dusting every now and then.'
That means we need continuous purification.
And Jesus said, 'He dusts us when he visits us with some tribulation so that I may remain
in them with more decorum, therefore become.'
In other words, purification has got to go on continuously because we cannot imagine the
humiliation it is for the Lord to come and dwell in us things of flesh.
We just can't imagine it.
So I want to give you Philippians 3, 18 for that.
'Later after I received communion, having renewed in me the pains of the crucifixion
Jesus added, my daughter, how precious the cross is.'
See now, in giving itself to the soul, the sacrament of my body unites her with me.
It transforms her to the point that she becomes one with me.
But as the species is consumed, which is only fifteen minutes, the union which is truly
established ceases, but not with the cross.
The cross takes God and unites him with the soul forever, and it places itself more surely
as a seal.
Therefore, the cross seals God in the soul.
Isn't that absolutely amazing?
In such a way that there is never separation between God and the crucified soul.
Now, the crucified soul is the one who is completely given to him and continues moment
by moment, hour by hour, day by day, continuously giving itself to him, giving itself, giving
itself, giving itself, sacrificing itself for love, sacrificing itself for love all the
time.
So divine will and love is the essence of what God has asked us to enter into.
So April the 23rd, 1900, he comes back to talk about resignation.
But he says it's like oil that is a salve for the body.
So finding this morning, finding myself outside of myself, I saw my sweet Jesus suffering
very much.
And I prayed him to share his pains with me and he said, "You too suffer.
Rather, I will take your place and you will do for me the office of a nurse."
Now, in volume two, he asked her to be a second mother for him on the earth so that he often
comes to her as an infant and asks her to do ministry to him.
And that simply is an illustration of, or shall I say, an explanation as to what her
ministry is in intercession and as a victim soul.
So now she's asked to be a nurse.
So it seemed that Jesus placed himself in my bed and I beside him began to check his
head, removing the thorns that were driven into it one by one.
Then I moved on to his body and visited all his wounds.
I dried up his blood, I kissed them, but I had nothing with me to salve them so as to
mitigate the spasm.
When I saw that oil was coming out from me, I took it and I salved the wounds of Jesus.
But with some concern, as I didn't understand what the meaning was of this oil coming out
of me, we'll talk about the oil first.
But blessed Jesus made me understand that resignation to the divine will is the oil, which while
salving and mitigating our pains, salves and mitigates the spasms of the wounds of Jesus
at the same time.
Because resignation cams and heals us from the agitation that we had beforehand.
Then after performing this office of my dear Jesus for quite some time, he disappeared
and I came back to myself.
Now you may wonder what on earth she's doing to the body of Christ.
But if you go into the hours of the passion, you have in the agony in the garden, you
have after the creation of the Eucharist and you have around the cross.
And she goes through all the wounds of Jesus making reparation, making reparation, making
reparation.
And she loves him for everyone in the divine will.
And she kisses him for everybody in the divine will and she offers reparation for all the
wounds from head to toe.
So that's what you're getting here in picture form.
April the 24th, 1900, the Eucharist and suffering.
This morning, having received communion, Louise said, it seemed to me that the confessor was
placing the intention of making me suffer the crucifixion.
And at that very instant, I saw my guardian angel who laid me on the cross to make me
suffer.
Now most of us don't think that the guardian angel will do that particular function.
But if you go to the prophet Daniel in the Old Testament, they prophet Ezekiel in the
Old Testament and the book of Revelation in the New Testament just to give you three examples.
You will find that it is the angels who always carry out God's will upon the earth.
So Louise's guardian angel laid her on the cross and made her suffer.
After this, she said, I saw my sweet Jesus who sympathized with me and told me, I am
your refreshment and my refreshment is your suffering for souls.
Now, that suffering for souls, of course, is the reparation that the victim soul does
and does it out of love.
So notice that this is reciprocal love from Jesus to the soul and vice versa.
And he showed an unspeakable contentment for my suffering and for the confessor who by
means of the obedience to suffer which he had given me had procured this relief for him.
Then he added, since the sacrament of the Eucharist is the flute of the cross, I feel
more disposed to concede suffering to you after you receive my body.
So you will have noticed from the very beginning that it's after Louise has received Holy Communion
that these communications about suffering take place.
In fact, in seeing you suffer, it seems to me, Jesus said, that I continue my passion
on the earth for the good of souls, not mystically, in other words, not in some very very place,
but really it's actually happening.
And this is a great relief for me because I collect the true fruit of the cross and of
the Eucharist.
So here you have Louise representing the body of Christ, going through the passion of Christ
on the earth.
And she can only do it bit by bit because after all, she's only a little creature.
Jesus was able to take it all at the same time.
After this Jesus said, "Up until now, it was obedience that made you suffer.
Do you want me to enjoy myself a little bit by renewing again in you the crucifixion with
my own hands?"
In other words, would you actually let me do it?
And Louise said, "Though I felt great suffering and still fresh the pains of the cross which
had been renewed in me, she said, 'I said, 'Lord, I'm in your hands.
Do with me whatever you want.'"
So that's like the Fiat of Blessed Mother in Luke 1.38.
Be it done unto me according to your word.
So all content, Jesus again began to drive the nails into my hands and feet.
I felt such intensity of pain that I myself do not know how I remained alive, but I was
content because I was making Jesus content.
Then after he bent the nails, placing himself near me, he said, "How beautiful you are."
But how much more does your beauty grow in suffering?
In other words, he's talking about interior beauty or how dear you are to me.
My eyes are wounded and looking at you because they see my very image in you.
That's Romans 8.29.
And he said many other things which would be useless to repeat first because I'm bad.
She said, "A second because not seeing myself as the Lord tells me.
I feel confusion and blushing in saying these things, but I hope that the Lord will make
me truly good and beautiful.
And then as my blushing would fade, I will be able to distribute them so I stop here.
I want to give you Galatians 2.19.
Now there's a mystery here.
Louisa is suffering the passion and she's allowed to suffer it just for a short time.
And that's because of the weakness of human flesh, otherwise we would kill her.
And then Jesus comes along and he says, "Would you like me to enjoy myself by giving you
the crucifixion myself?
That we really need to think about this."
Because when we think of the crucifixion of Christ, we have this image of the baddies
in Israel hating Jesus and causing him all kinds of terrifying pains and we have that
baddie pilot who is condemning him on jostly and blah, blah, blah.
And we don't realize that none of that could have happened if Jesus hadn't willed it and
if Jesus hadn't actually surrendered his divine power and if Jesus hadn't surrendered
to them and that he wanted this suffering in order to be able to show us the utter limits
of love.
In order to be able to show us that as far as God is concerned, God would do anything
to save us.
He would do anything to let us know that he considered us very precious.
And to let us know that God is completely different to what we think, that God himself
wanted to pay this infinite debt.
It's just amazing.
You know the parable about the unforgiving debtor.
That unforgiving debtor represents every sinner that ever lived.
And when we commit a sin, we're sinning against an infinite being, therefore the debt is infinite.
And therefore just as you're told in the parable that no matter what the man did or suffered,
he could never ever pay the debt.
So the only chance he had of anything was to throw himself at the mercy of a king who
was going to condemn him.
And the moment he throws himself at the mercy of the king, he gets instant and absolute
forgiveness.
Now you would expect this person to suffer from some kind of psychological shock.
One minute I'm being sold in slavery myself, my wife and my children, to try and pay a
debt that I can't pay, and all of a sudden I'm free.
And so you're completely and totally shocked when the man doesn't even say, gee, thanks.
There's no gratitude in him.
There's no humility in him, there's no love in him, and he shows this by maltreating one
of his fellow servants.
So the unforgiving debtor is us because throughout these writings, Jesus identifies the human
race as the ungrateful one, the one who does not appreciate what was done for them, does
not say thank you, does not take the gift and let it do the work that it can do in us.
And so it's a terrible picture of us.
And so when Jesus says to Louisa, can I actually get you to participate in this mystery from
me, he's talking about the fact that Louisa explains in the agony, in the garden, in
the hours of the passion, that Jesus suffered a passion of love given to him directly by
the father, the passion of sin given by us, and then what she calls the passion of the
Jews, in other words, what human beings did to him in the crucifixion.
But the worst passion was the passion of love.
The second worst one was the passion of sin that made him sweat blood.
Okay.
So Jesus is asking Louisa to participate in this extraordinary mystery, that she would
allow the passion of love to happen, and therefore she would be very, very, very much in the
image of Jesus.
That's what's causing him joy, that somebody else is willing to give this sign to the father
that they love God beyond reason, and they love their neighbor beyond reason as well.
So it's a wonderful thing that's happening there.
That's why he tells her how beautiful you are, and your beauty grows in suffering.
It's because of this unbelievable love that's behind it.
Okay.
So let's go on to April the 25th, 1900, where we talk about purity of intention.
Now, this is one of the vital lessons in volumes one to four, that we are told that we must
have purity of intention.
That means you have only one reason for doing something, and the only intention that's accepted
in the divine will spirituality is that you do everything for love of Jesus.
Let me give you an example of an intention that's not pure.
More means unmixed with something else.
Okay.
Virgin means untouched by something else.
So let me give you an example of impurity of intention.
So I tell my friends and my family that I'm going to fast for a few days, you know, and
everybody says, "Oh, isn't she so religious, isn't it fantastic, you know, she's doing
this incredible thing that we couldn't do," and blah, blah, blah.
But in the back of my head, I'm saying to myself, "But I could lose a few pounds as
well."
Now, it's that thought in the back of my head that makes the whole thing impure and makes
the fasting of no value whatsoever, there's poison in the intention.
I get that clearly, and you'll understand why Jesus comes back time after time to tell
us that we must have purity of intention, that we do something for one reason only,
and that one reason is to love Jesus.
If you want to see this very clearly, you'll see it in the writings of Saint Therese of
Lesus, where she continuously says she's doing everything for love of Jesus, for Jesus alone,
for love of Jesus.
No matter what it is, she's doing it for love of Him.
You repent for love of Him, you serve your neighbor for love of Him, you deny yourself
for love of Him, you pray for love of Him, you do everything for Him.
So this is April the 25th, 1900.
As I was in my usual state and not finding my sweet Jesus, I had to go around very much
to go and search of Him.
Finally, I found Him in the arms of our Queen Mother, suckling milk from her breasts.
As much as I said and did, He did not seem to pay attention to me what child would pay
attention to you when they are receiving life from their mothers.
Who can say the pain of my poor heart in seeing Jesus and not paying attention to me?
Then after I gave vent to my tears, having compassion on me, he came into my arms and
poured from his mouth a little bit of that milk which he had suckled from his mother.
Now look at the cycle of life that's going on here.
The milk went from her to Him and from Him to Louisa.
Now milk represents life for an infant, so this is divine life being passed on.
After this she said, "I looked into his breast and he had a little pearl so refulgent as to
invest his holy humanity with light," wanting to know the meaning of this pearl, I asked
Jesus what it was, which while it seemed so small was spreading an awful lot of light.
And Jesus said, "This pearl is the purity of your suffering," which though small, because
we're only one little human being, "it is the cause of so much light because you suffer
only for love of me," there's the purity of intention.
And you would be ready to suffer more if I conceded it to you.
My daughter, purity in operating or working whatever you're doing is so great that one
who works with the sole purpose of pleasing me alone does nothing other than spread light
from everything they do.
Now you need to take that little statement out of the book, write it on the back of an
old envelope, read it, read it, read it, read it, read it until it gets into you.
And I want to give you John 8.29.
For this I only do what pleases him, Jesus said, he only operated to please the Father
when he was on the earth.
So let me just read that for you again.
My daughter, purity in working, that is in all your works, is so great that one who operates
with the sole purpose of pleasing me alone does nothing other than spread light from
all that he does.
One who does not operate in this upright way, you see, if it's not upright it'll be impure
motivation which I've illustrated for you, even in good, does nothing other than spread
darkness.
So that's John 3.19 to 21.
Then I looked into the heart, the breast of Jesus, and he had a most clear mirror.
And it seemed that those who walked in an upright way, that is with purity of intention,
remained completely absorbed in that mirror, while those who did not remained outside without
being able to receive any imprint of the image of blessed Jesus.
Now you really need to look at that, that if we're doing stuff for ourselves or with
mixed motivation, you don't receive any imprint of the image of blessed Jesus.
That's frightening.
"Ah Lord," she said, "keep me all absorbed in this divine mirror that I may have no
other shade of intention, of course, except in loving you."
So May the first 1900, we come back to the Eucharist and the Cross again.
After I received communion, my sweet Jesus made himself seen all friendly.
And as it seemed that the confessor was placing the intention of the crucifixion, my nature
felt almost a repugnance to submit itself.
And I find that very comforting that while Louisa was always willing to suffer, there
were times when human nature didn't really want to be that sacrificial.
And it just tells us how human and real she was.
My sweet Jesus to cheer me told me, "My daughter, if the Eucharist is the deposit of
future glory, that is John 654, the cross is the disbursement with which to purchase
it."
So the Eucharist is the deposit of future glory, but you will get it through the cross.
He says the payment.
If the Eucharist is the seed that prevents corruption, like those aromatic herbs that
prevent decomposition when applied to corpses.
The Eucharist gives immortality to the soul and eventually to the body.
The cross embellishes and is so powerful that if deaths of sin have been contracted,
it becomes their guarantor.
And it more surely obtains the restitution of the deaths deed.
Now this is given to us in official language.
The Church has always taught us that if we receive communion worthily, that the stains
of involuntary sin and defects will be cleansed in our souls.
And after the Eucharist has satisfied every dead, it forms the soul in the soul, sorry.
After the Eucharist has satisfied every dead, it forms for the soul the most refulgent throne
for your future glory.
That's all in John 6 that you'll have everlasting life.
Ah yes, the cross and the Eucharist alternate naturally, and one operates more powerfully
than the other.
You need both, and God loves us so much that he makes sure that we have both, not just
one of them.
And any added, the cross is my flowery bed.
That's an amazing image.
Not because I did not suffer harrowing spasms, but because by means of the cross I delivered
many souls to grace.
And I could see many beautiful flowers bloom which would produce many celestial fruits.
So for that I want to give you Galatians 6, 14, and Hebrews 12 verses 1 to 4.
I also want to give you Revelation 5 from verses 6 to 10, okay.
So what Jesus is saying here, I'll give it to you from Hebrews, that Hebrews reference
that I've just given to you.
Hebrews 12-2 says that for the joy that was set before him, Jesus endured the cross despising
the shame.
In other words, he was looking for the celestial fruits of the sacrifice.
So let's look at this again.
The cross is my flowery bed, in other words, the place where he's going to have a rich
harvest.
Not because I didn't suffer harrowing spasms, but because by means of the cross I deliver
many souls to grace.
And I could see many beautiful flowers bloom.
So these are the special flowers in the Kingdom of God, we call them saints, which would produce
many celestial fruits.
So in seeing so much good I held that bed of suffering as my delight, and I delighted
in the cross and in suffering.
You too, my daughter, take pains as delights and delight in being crucified on my cross.
And that is because Louisa is aware of the fact that every single time she takes any aspect
of the crucifixion that there's going to be an incredible harvest.
And so he says I do not want you to fear suffering, almost wanting to act like a slugger, meaning
someone who doesn't put up with it really.
Oppie said, courage, be brave, and on your own expose yourself to suffering.
Now what is he saying?
Up to now Louisa was saying, oh if obedient says it, I'll go along with it.
If obedient says it, if obedient says it, so Jesus is saying to her, why don't you
participate now, and you yourself can ask for the cross?
As he was saying this, I saw my good guardian angel ready to crucify me.
She said, I stretched out my arms on my own, which is exactly what Jesus was saying.
You yourself participate more.
In other words, he's saying to her, he has been saying to her since volume one, you must
be an exact image of me.
But Jesus chose the cross as a means of redemption.
And he chose all the dreadful sufferings that he had, not because he enjoyed the sufferings,
but because it was going to have such an immense fruit.
So he's saying to her that she could step forward as well in the same way.
And she did.
She's very good.
I stretched out my arms on my own, she said, and the angel crucified me.
Oh, how good Jesus delighted in my suffering simply because she has stepped forward much
better in her role of another Christ.
And how content I was, she said, that such a miserable soul could give pleasure to Jesus.
It seemed a great honor for me to suffer for love of him.
So on May the third 1900, we have something that we wouldn't know about unless Louisa
actually told us that there is a feast of the cross in heaven.
Now, she doesn't tell us when it is.
We know that August the 15th is the feast of the divine will in heaven.
That's what Jesus said to Louisa, but she doesn't actually give us a date.
So the feast of the cross, now, first of all, I want to give you a whole lot of references
because I want to read the text continuously.
I want to give you two Corinthians chapter 1, verses 3 to 11.
I want to give you Romans 8, 18, Matthew 16, 24, Luke 14, 27, 1 Peter 4, 13, and Colossians
2, 24.
Now you're going to have to look them up.
That's your exercise.
This morning I find myself outside of myself, Louisa said, and I saw all of heaven studded
with crosses, some small, some large, some medium, some which were larger, emanated,
more splendor.
It was a most sweet enchantment to see so many crosses adorning the firmament, more
effulgent than suns.
Then it seemed that heaven opened, and one could see and hear the feast that the blessed
were making for the cross in heaven.
Those who had suffered more were celebrated more in heaven on this particular day.
One could distinguish in a special way the martyrs and those who had suffered for God
in a hidden way.
Oh, how esteemed were the cross and those who suffered more in this blessed dwelling.
Now everybody gets a little bit of the cross, Jesus tells us that himself, that he placed
every single one of us in the cross when he picked it up, to carry it to Calvary.
But the people who suffer in a hidden way is mostly a reference to the victim's souls
who are prepared to suffer incredibly, not because they have to suffer, because they
offer themselves to be the person who stands in the breach between divine justice and the
sinfulness of the human race.
And so they are the martyrs of love, and Jesus always calls them the loving souls, the ones
that he has special predilection for.
Now there are lots of other people who suffer in a hidden way because of their humility.
These are probably not aware of themselves being victim's souls in any way, and they
may be.
And because of their humility and their shyness, if I can put it that way, the Lord lets them
suffer and even maybe the people in their own household doesn't realize that they have
saints on their hands.
As I was seeing this, a voice resounded throughout the whole of heaven saying, "If the Lord did
not send crosses upon the earth, he would be like a father who has no love for his children,
who wants to see them poor and dishonored instead of honored and rich."
Now, since volume one, we've been told so much about the cross that I don't need to
go into it there.
The cross is the instrument for purification, salvation, and glorification for us if we
enter into it.
The rest that I saw during this feast, Louisa, said, "I've no words to describe it."
So she leaves it there.
So May the 9th, 1900, Louisa sees the mystery of the most holy trinity in the form of three
suns.
You see, we're back to this image of the sun again because the sun is the source of light.
And it's when I read these readings about the sun being the source of light and that Jesus
can speak so much through it.
It makes me have compassion for the old pharaohs in Egypt who worshiped the sun as a god.
They called it Ra.
And the pharaoh of the Exodus was called Ra Misei.
That means the son of the son god.
Now, they worshiped the sun because it was the source of light and heat and that it fertilized
everything on the earth and that life on the earth wasn't possible.
The reason why I have compassion for them is that they were not completely wrong.
That if they could only have moved a step further and realized that there was a person
behind the sun, it would have been the most wonderful stage for the human race.
It's a bit like an infant at its mother's breast.
It's only a few days or a few weeks old and it's sucking away and it looks up and discovers
the first major discovery of its life that there's a person behind the food.
And it's a very wonderful moment for both the mother and the child when the little hand
comes up to touch the mother's face.
There's a person behind the food and then the mother's hand goes down to the child's
face.
Yes.
It's a person who loves you.
It's not a thing.
It's most wonderful and it helps me to intercede for the pharaohs.
So Louisa said, "This is May the 9th, 1900.
After I'd gone through days not only of privation but also of disturbance now she's not supposed
to be disturbed because the Lord wants us to be in complete calm.
This morning as I was yet more disturbed about my miserable state, adorable Jesus on coming
said to me, 'By being restless you have disturbed my sweet rest.'"
So I want to give you Sam 132 verse 8 that the Lord rests in the soul who is at peace.
Ah yes, he said, "You do not let me rest anymore."
And Matthew 11, 28 to 30, Jesus invited us to come and rest in him.
And in Hebrews 4 from verse 3, up to verse 5 or 6, we can enter into his rest.
But it should be a mutual rest because if there is peace in me and he is the king of
peace, if there is love in me and he is the king of love, then it's mutual rest.
So that's Sam 62 as well.
My soul rests in God.
And the Sam says it over and over again.
So Jesus is saying to her, "By being restless you have disturbed my rest."
And you won't even let me rest anymore.
Who can say how mortified I was, Louisa, said on hearing this that I had deprived Jesus
of his rest?
In spite of this I calmed down only for a few hours and then I found myself more restless
than before because if you are disturbed interiorly, you don't overcome it easily.
It keeps, it's like the waves of the sea.
It keeps coming in, coming back.
It takes quite a bit to overcome it completely.
So after those few words spoken by Jesus, I found myself outside of myself and looking
into the vault of the heavens, I saw three suns, capital S.
One seemed to set in the east, one in the west and the third in the south.
The splendor of the rays that they sent forth was so great that they united with one another
in such a way as to become one.
Now I don't know the significance of one of the suns representing one of the persons
of the rest of Trinity setting in the east and then the west and then the south, but
I'm going to make a suggestion and you have to understand that ladies are not allowed
to be infallible so I could be completely wrong.
If you study the Bible, God the Father made his rest in the chosen people and there in
the Middle East and so all the Bible is about the Middle East.
Jesus, God the Son, made his rest in the church and the church moved completely into the west.
Now if this is telling us that the Holy Spirit is going to find his rest in the south of
the world, that's very interesting.
I could be wrong, I've said it before.
Louisa says the splendor of the rays that they sent forth was so great that they united
with one another in such a way as to become one.
I seemed to see the mystery of the most holy trinity here and man formed with the three
powers in its image.
Now the three powers are the intellect, memory and will.
I also understood that for one who stayed in the light, his will would be transformed
by the Father.
His intellect would be transformed by the Son and his memory would be transformed by
the Holy Spirit.
How many things I understood, but I'm unable to manifest them.
We have to wait for the higher volumes for Louisa to begin really writing what she sees.
So I'll give you one more.
May the 13th 1900, this was the weight of the privation of Jesus.
I continued in the same state and maybe even worse Louisa said, though I do as much as
I can to remain peaceful without getting disturbed because obedience is demanding it.
But in spite of this, I do not cease to feel the weight of the abandonment that presses
upon me and reaches the point of crushing me.
And that's the weight of the privation of Jesus.
Now for this I want to give you Sam 22, verse 1, my God, my God, why have you forsaken me?
And also I want to give you Sirak chapter 2, my son, if you desire to serve the Lord,
prepare yourself for an ordeal because gold is tested in the fire and chosen men.
People are tested in the furnace of humiliation.
Also want to give you wisdom 9, 15, which you can look up yourself.
And Louisa says, what a state this is.
Tell me at least where have I offended you.
Now she keeps she persists in that and Jesus persists in telling her it's nothing to do
with any offense.
What is the cause of your abandonment?
Oh Lord, if you want to continue this way, I think I will not be able to endure anymore.
Then he made himself seen for just a little and placing a hand under my chin to encourage
her and to raise her up.
You know, the old definition for prayer was the raising of the mind and the heart to God.
And so Jesus is tipping the chin up to try and get her to think.
And he said, my poor daughter, how you have reduced yourself and sharing his pains with
me.
He disappeared like lightning, leaving me more afflicted than before.
Now all he did was made that very simple gesture of raising her chin.
As if he had not come, or rather I feel as if he had not come for such a long time and
I feel such afflicted that though I live, my living is a continuous agonizing.
In other words, she's she's teetering between life and death as the way she feels.
And it's best expressed in Sam 42 and Sam 63, our Lord, she said, lend me help and do
not leave me in disabandonment, though I deserve it.
Okay.
So she realizes that humility is the safe place to be.
So I go to leave it there for a while.